berlin's Brett Chad plots on Christmas
Eve for investigators of the attack
there's barely been a moment's rest Omri
hadn't initially come to the attention
of German security services well before
this moment they were investigating his
connection to Islamist preacher abu
allah german broadcaster ard revealed
that two informants infiltrated the
extremist network one said the following
in a secret report contact too honest
amrut was initially established through
an informant who was guided by the north
rhine-westphalia police in the following
days Omri revealed that he intended to
carry out attacks in Germany using
weapons of war Omri was due to be
deported back to his home in Tunisia in
Tunis people held rallies against
Islamist terrorism on Saturday Tunisian
authorities also arrested three men who
were supposed to be connections to Omri
one of them is his nephew amras
relatives have criticized the actions of
Italian police they say he should have
been arrested and interrogated there was
a big secret behind him they killed him
with this secret they killed my son with
all his secrets I want to know the truth
of my son I want to know who brainwashed
him I want my son to be returned I will
not accept condolences without knowing
the truth behind my son I asked the
Tunisian and German authorities for the
truth about my son why he was killed why
they didn't detain him and investigate
who was behind him lemon Omri was shot
and killed in milan on friday what he
was doing there is still unclear perhaps
he had support from a network
investigators still have many open
questions to address